there's something about the walking dead  it makes it I think very different from  and certainly any other show I've worked  on these these great characters small  and large that are just so much fun to  write for let Mark's face be a daily  reminder to him and everyone else that  the rules matter I think the thing I  love about the show is that it's this  emotional character storytelling well  bury our dead we Barnum because this is  actually more of a character drama that  happens to be set in a genre world it's  my dream job it feels like a show that  changes like life does but it's all  based on these characters that we like  that we like hanging out with all the  characters are pretty awesome but for me  my favorite character this season has  been this is the kind of thing that just  tickles my balls who says things that we  just don't expect to come out of his  mouth and writing dialogue for that  characters a lot of fun got my fingers  crossed for a little freaking binky